on dit de vous que vous êtes une
battante une élue du terrain une femme
politique passionnée à l'ascension
fulgurante vous portez avec conviction
le SNU pouvez-vous revenir brièvement
sur ce parcours et sur votre engagement
auprès des jeunes alors très rapidement
déjà ça me touche beaucoup donc je suis
assez ému quand ça commence comme ça en
général c'est parfois plus plus critique
ce qui est certain c'est que moi je
crois que le ré français il existe et ce
rêve français c'est la capacité à se
dépasser apparaisser dans des cases ou
dans des caricatures il se trouve que
moi je suis partie d'une génération où
moi mes parents sont venus en France et
on fait que nous on a pu grandir en
France aller à l'école
mais pour autant on sent se dire que
notre destin était hypothéqué par la
définition des autres et pour ça et bien
fait plein de choix fais plein de
parcours je finis à romorantin-lantenay
dans le Loir-et-Cher j'ai créé ma
première entre 8 ma première entreprise
à 18 ans je me suis engagé politiquement
pareil autour de 18 ans et finalement
est apparrêtable j'ai toujours considéré
qu'on pouvait changer les choses pour
soi pour les autres mais aussi pour la
société pour la rendre plus juste en
tout cas plus à notre image mais il
fallait des rencontres il manque des
trucs encore et ces trucs c'est parfois
de la confiance en soi parfois un petit
coup de main bancaire dans le monde
politique c'est parfois un mentor des
des règles qui ne sont écrites nulle
part et tout ça c'est possible si on
crée plus de liens et si on donne les
moyens à chacun de trouver où se trouve
ces informations là c'est ce qui m'a
amené aujourd'hui à être je crois plus
que jamais militante d'abord du lien
social mais aussi un peu d'audace et
beaucoup de mérites bravo bravo pour ce
joli parcours après une première
expérimentation en 9 et une deuxième
donc une édition 2020 perturbé un peu
par la crise le SNU est monté depuis en
puissance en quoi ce dispositif peut-il
aider les jeunes des quartiers au monde
entrepreneurial en fait le sénu c'est un
de ces projets qui est très peu connu et
beaucoup caricaturé manière très simple
on sait pas ce que signifie dans notre
pays un service civile ou un service
civique alors tout le monde le compare
au service militaire ou à la colonie de
vacances alors en vrai c'est le meilleur
du service militaire le meilleur de la
commune de vacances c'est le meilleur de
l'école tout ça dans un temps qui est
organisé de 12 jours en dehors de son
département pour les jeunes de 15 à 17
ans ensuite on a une mission d'intérêt
général on va nous donner de son temps
mais déjà une de moins de 18 ans et on
ouvre les hôpitaux les préfectures les
EHPAD les gendarmeries on ouvre tous les
endroits où les jeunes n'ont pas accès
d'habitude et ensuite un service long
qui s'appelle service civique mais
surtout la vraie différence dans ce
projet c'est que il faut être candidat
il faut vouloir y aller et c'est encore
c'est encore le frein parce qu'il est
pas très connu c'est totalement gratuit
je le répète parce que beaucoup imagine
que ça coûte de l'argent et pour les
jeunes qui sont des quartiers ou même de
zone rurales plus isolées ou même les
outre-mer ce qui est nouveau c'est la
mobilité c'est le fait de se dire je
peux partir en dehors de ma région
dormir avec des gens que je ne connais
pas
parfois porté parfois par an uniforme
c'est les mêmes tenues pour vivre ce
sentiment d'appartenance personne te
demande quelle est ta classe sociale
qu'elle est quels sont les études que tu
fais personne ne sait ça on ne retient
que ton engagement ta mobilisation ton
goût de la curiosité aussi et cette
confiance en soi qu'on acquiert quand on
part et qu'on revient et bien c'est un
ressort pour toute la vie et c'est cet
élément émancipateur là qu'on a envie de
faire vivre à toute une jeunesse et
c'est génial en fait je me dis juste que
j'ai envie de le vivre pourquoi ça
n'existait pas moi quand j'étais plus
jeune c'est vrai que c'est réservé aux
jeunes jusqu'à 17 ans mais vous pouvez
venir moi je vous invite d'ailleurs
profite de cette tribune je vous invite
à venir témoigner parce que c'est des
parcours comme les votes qui comptent
moi les jeunes que l'on reçoit et
parfois il leur montre que des preuves
de ce qu'on dit Candy la France a un
pays où c'est possible avec le mérite
avec l'effort parfois il te regarde avec
des yeux mais très sincère mais
c'est des mots quoi enfin c'est joli
hein moi aussi j'aime bien l'idée du
rêve français mais autour de moi je ne
connais pas ce que tu dis et donc face à
ça je pense qu'il faut des preuves et
autour de ce plateau c'est plein de rôle
modèle et c'est pour ça que chiche s'est
lancé on m'a dit que vous étiez
extrêmement audacieuse aussi et ben
c'est on va lancer les témoignages de
rodmodel dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat aussi c'est pas de
hiérarchiser en fait non mais tout à
fait il y a l'objectif premier c'est
d'abord de faire rencontrer des jeunes
qui viennent vraiment de milieux
différents on se rend compte que leur
vie elles seront liées de toute façon et
et casser des caricatures des barrières
parfois des stéréotypes de vie et de se
dire bah en fait je m'interdis rien
parce que j'aurais découvert le premier
frein dans notre pays c'est le fait de
ne pas connaître les projets des
dispositifs ce qu'il offre d'un pays
magnifique mais en fait il est
magnifique que si tu le vois donc si tu
ne le sais pas ça passe à côté de toi
sur le SNU moi je suis extrêmement
favorable à faire témoigner parce que
mon intime conviction est d'ailleurs
c'était déjà c'est le cas sous l'ancien
de l'ancien mandat moi j'ai demandé un
j'ai demandé un rapport génial à deux
personnes un parlementaire qui
s'appelait monsieur puponi et un super
ami qui est devenu un ami depuis qui
s'appelle Hamon qu'un entrepreneur
génial 200 000 entrepreneurs exactement
et tellement génial que il a écrit un
rapport disons qu'il fallait alimenter
l'esprit d'entreprendre parce que en
fait mon combat il est où il est que si
tu crées une boîte c'est très bien si tu
arrives finalement à en vivre créer des
emplois c'est canon c'est parfait un
jeune sur deux veut créer une entreprise
donc l'esprit il est là mais il faut
donner les moyens mais si tu as cet
esprit d'entreprendre demain tu vas pas
t'interdire une mobilité changer de
département pour aller pour faire des
études pour un stage tu vas pas
t'interdire de t'engager politiquement
sur ton territoire peut-être que tu vas
même être plus acteur de ta vie donc
être moins malheureux dans le fond donc
cet esprit d'entre eux d'entrepreneur
c'est une sorte de ressort
tu peux tu peux faire de l'intra
entrepreneuriat au lieu parfois juste de
critiquer de transformer l'entreprise de
l'Intérieur faire faire que elle ressent
plus à tes convictions peut-être plus au
sens que tu recherches et donc juste de
ne pas être un témoin de sa propre vie
ça ça va être français ça c'est être
entrepreneur
pour juste rapidement conclure l'idée
sur le stage de 3e
elle est bonne la réalité est que moi
juste une crainte toujours très intime
qui me dit que si on ne se bat pas pour
que tous les jeunes puissent faire un
stage intéressant alors peut-être ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin ne le ferez
pas il se trouve que ce matin même
j'étais avec des une fondation qui
s'engage pour le stage de 3e moi j'ai
envie qu'au contraire on puisse
découvrir un maximum on sait très bien
que le premier frein dans notre pays
c'est le réseau si on sait pas qui
donner son stage et bien plus que jamais
on a besoin des réseaux sociaux et de la
formation qui permettra et encore une
fois les réseaux sociaux ce ne sont que
des outils donc au lieu d'avoir peur et
on avait en coulisse si au lieu d'avoir
peur de chat gepetti de l'intelligence
artificielle de la blockchain des NFC
faisons que tous ces outils d'avenir
soit
finement approprié qu'on puisse les
maîtriser qu'on sache ce que ça signifie
et accompagnons les parents parce que
les parents sont des passages
aujourd'hui et si on fait ça et ben dans
le fond on laisse chacun bâtir sa propre
vie et il y aura pas de jugement mais il
y aura de l'égalité est-ce que vous
proposez Béatrice
arrêter le stade c'est pas d'arrêter le
stage
possible le risque non parce que si vous
faites une alternative qui est positive
et qui permet aux jeunes de rencontrer
en fait finalement plein de
professionnels
la question c'est si tu ça ne permet pas
de vivre la mobilité de commencer à
l'entreprise de l'intérieur mais dans le
fond je préfère encore vivre ça que de
voir des jeunes sans stage du tout puni
voir se rendre compte
il faut juste raconter qui on est pour
rendre possible aux jeunes la capacité
de se projeter il y a aucune hiérarchie
de se rendre visible bien sûr ça devient
tangible et dans le fond un gouvernement
c'est quoi son rôle c'est de donner
accès à l'information de donner accès
aux outils d'éduquer à utiliser ces
outils mais aussi à permettre des
statuts le droit à l'erreur junior
entreprise dès le collège au sein de
quelques lycées qui sont plutôt allant
le statut de Junior d'étudiant
entrepreneurs la Junior Entreprise
Innovante ça c'est le rôle du
gouvernement c'est de mettre aussi en
place des outils qui permettent
d'essayer de tester parce que parfois on
est quand on est plus jeune et bien
c'est plus difficile et quand on a les
moyens on prend le risque de le faire
quand on a un peu moins les moyens et
bien au début on se dit quel est mon
choix rationnel répondre à mes besoins
ou de lancer une entreprise parfois on
fait les deux en même temps parfois
pendant les études mais ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut et bien lever
ces freins c'est doute c'est ça
permettre le passage c'est le début
pour rassurer peut-être tout le monde
tout ce qui est présenté aux jeunes dans
le service national passe par un comité
scientifique de validation des projets
pédagogiques ce sont des jeunes mineurs
dont l'État à la responsabilité pleine
et entière et donc évidemment tout est
ultra cadré je rappelle enfin je
rappelle juste que ces jeunes sont
souvent
là parce que leurs parents font
confiance à l'institution éducation
nationale et que on conjugue les toutes
les forces de notre pays associative
entrepreneuriale mais aussi évidemment
voilà des élus des des assos sportives
pour donner les moyens aux